joe biden
nice old uncle joe
the mature
respectful
responsible adult in the room
nice guy the return to normal
was just asked a totally fair question
about immigration by peter ducey member
of the
white house press pool
and and joe biden
got caught on microphone
calling him a very naughty name
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound a little bit
the more inflation you're going to ask
me about more inflation you you dirty
rotten journalist you scum of the earth
you you you're slime you're the enemy of
the people you how dare you ask me a
totally fair question you stupid son of
a gun he didn't say son of a gun he was
nastier than that
first takeaway joe biden is a mean and
nasty and small man and he always has
been and the idea that he's this nice
warm guy who licks ice cream cones and
pats little kids on the head is a media
contrivance he's a jerk he's a mean
nasty shallow jerk don't forget what he
did to corn pop poor corn pop over there
at the delaware swimming pool and joe
biden was really mean and nasty to him
and he's been mean and nasty for his
whole career
he was willing to let
clarence thomas
be smeared dragged through the mud on
bogus charges a high-tech lynching he
was happy to do it
until clarence thomas acknowledged that
called him out on that at his hearing
finally joe biden relented joe biden who
said that mitt romney wants to put black
people back in chains joe biden
who
a petulant
stupid uneducated man at a presidential
debate
interjecting whenever donald trump would
make a point say you're racist you're
racist you're you're you're you're mean
you're racist
racism is the what's the worst thing you
could call somebody in the country
racist he keeps doing it smeared a 17
year old kid kyle rittenhouse call in a
presidential campaign ad said he was
said he was a racist because it's the
worst thing that you can call somebody
in america today
launched his presidential campaign on
the lie that donald trump called
neo-nazis fine people at charlottesville
he's just a he's just a dirty rotten
nasty ugly man i don't i don't know how
else to put it
and he says this sort of thing about
peter ducey now
i like peter ducey but
journalists can take it i don't i don't
mind it when politicians go a little
hard after journalists my only problem
here
is the double standard donald trump
calls the press the enemy of the people
and you you see commercials
as though as though the journalists are
little orphan children with sarah
mclaughlin playing in the background you
know you've got don lemon and chris
cuomo in the arms of the angel you know
like these these poor little babes where
if you besmirch their high honor you
know at cnn that somehow you're
threatening our constitution but then
this jerk gets asked a completely fair
question about why inflation is going
through the roof historic decades high
inflation said you stupid sun how dare
you ask me about why are you doing this
but i guess i guess one of the reasons
why joe biden is
so on edge right now
other than his
manifest senility is that right now
we may see war break out in ukraine we
might see a russian invasion of ukraine
and we might be involved in that war do
you not get enough respect i'll tell you
me i get no respect no respect i tell
you well that was true before i became a
lord that's right i am lord michael
knowles i can prove it i've got my
certificate from established titles
which is a terrific way to play on an
old scottish custom to to refer to
landowners as lairds or lords and ladies
in english with established titles you
will get your title pack you will
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
with your certificate you can officially
change your name to lord or lady you can
get it on your credit card or airplane
tickets you can put it on your dating
profiles it's a great way to connect
with your family if you happen to be
scottish it's a great way to get some
respect if you're like me and it helps
to
preserve nature because established
titles has partnered with a lot of
really great conservation charities so
you're helping the planet while you do
it they're having an extended new year
sale right now head on over to
establishtitles.com
save ten percent off today remember to
use the discount code knowles kwles or
just click the link below that is
established titles dot com slash knowles
we should change that url though it
should be slash lord knowles
i'll talk to establish titles head on
over there become a lord or a lady
yourself
i'm glad you like that clip i i'm glad
you showed up now if you want to show up
for more clips you've got to ring the
bell subscribe get those notifications
i hope you get the notifications even
once you ring that bell
if you don't head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
type in do to do the michael knowles
show doo doo doo subscribe leave a five
star review boom boom boom dude hack the
mainframe you're all good we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]